[Music]
tracy's in birmingham
hi tracy welcome to the ramsey show
hi um my question
is i am married to a self-made
millionaire
we've been married for three years
together for a total of
seven um i
put my career on hold and i kind of help
him with
everything his businesses multiple
businesses
and everything i well the one
job that i have that i actually get a
paid salary from
is i am a project slash office manager
for an electrical contracting company
and we do jobs across the nation so that
is the one job that i do to actually get
a salary
for but on top of that i help them with
everything
of his other businesses that he has and
all his personal things like you know
like a normal couple would but
um
when we got married i signed a prenup
because i know you know i understand
that you
um everything before me is yours and
your
success is yours um
but i'm starting to feel like we're
never going to build
together and i've put my career on hold
and i'm helping out with him and his
things
so
[Music]
tracy what else is going on um
there's actually a lot um
i've been wanting to have kids
and that's something that i feel like
he's stringing me along with as well
um and i feel like
everything in our lives is his like
there's nothing that's ours like
i don't feel like he values my opinion
or
you know why you feel this way because
that's the truth it's true
that's why you feel this way yeah you're
not crazy and um
yeah i think that you say that john
because
he has been saying that i need to go to
a psychiatrist
yes because there's no reason why i
should be unhappy with my life because
he provides me with all these
things except for don't ask for
except for meaning he tells you what
you're gonna like and what you're gonna
love and what you need and then he
provides that
without giving you any input on the
things that you want and need
and you're living somebody else's life
it is correct just like we all um
we all got bite no we didn't all people
got biden checks
they didn't get value and purpose right
it's very similar
right you're not crazy it's the
gaslighter special
when you say hey i'm not doing okay and
they say well you should probably go see
somebody
right yeah dave said it the right he
was right on you feel this way because
it's true
yeah and i um i'm a very hard worker i'm
very frugal
you said you've been married three years
how old are you i'm 35.
old she he is 51.
yeah he's acting like a daddy yep
it's not just the year differentiation
you're acting like in a daughter slash
employee
yeah he's a wee bit overbearing don't
you think
i feel that like i am more of an
employee yeah
i wonder what would happen if you quit
um i have
i have threatened that in the past
i'm saying what would happen i think the
dynamic would change
it changes for a moment and then
you know he says all the right things
and then hold on
what do you get what are you getting
paid to be the
project coordinator at slash
administrative assistant what do you
make a year um
approximately like fifty thousand
dollars okay
you can go find another fifty thousand
dollar job yeah go find a different job
go find a different job oh yeah
absolutely and the thing that he always
says
is that i am spoiled and entitled
because
he pays all the bills which he has i
don't care what he says anymore
all of a sudden what he says doesn't
matter i've heard enough of it yeah you
don't work for him anymore
now y'all have a chance to work on your
marriage because i need to go get a job
somewhere else and get a marriage
counselor and if he won't go
go without him and let the marriage
counselor navigate you through
uh setting this guy up for one possible
chance to win
or two possible chances to win and then
this isn't gonna go well yeah it's
already not going well yeah
i'm so sorry i'm heartbroken for you
somewhere around two percent of the
public should be institutionalized
probably it's probably higher than that
crazier than a bean so let me tell you
how crazy
there's nothing crazier than a crazy
christian either
so deborah from maryland calls at the
break won't go on the air and tells
kelly to tell you and i that we missed
the last call
that we screwed up the poor lady who's
being uh over who's dealing with an
overbearing out-of-control husband
and says that you and i are not very
christian because if we were real
christians we would have told the woman
to submit and she would be happy
this is what you call an idiot whoa
deborah you're an idiot we didn't miss
it you did and people like you give
christianity a bad name
when you misinterpret scripture and you
think that someone should live in a
toxic situation
with an abusive husband and you call
that submission
that's not submission that's idiocy wow
was i unclear i don't i don't fully
understand what you're talking about
justin
can you help me goodness gracious
oh man well the proof that there will
always be a need for your show
and mine the future mental health
practitioners of america thank you
wow that breaks my heart man yeah well i
mean
yeah you're yeah you want your daughter
in that no so
you she want her daughter in that no her
daughter walks in and is traded that way
you should just submit it i just want oh
cool wow
yeah as as as two guys who have
daughters who are
brilliant and intelligent and very nice
two guys who have wonderful strong
brilliant wives golly who are not
overbearing and don't tell us what to do
but we're not overbearing and tell them
what to do we like work as a team
yeah submit yourselves one to another
it should be a race that's the scripture
thing yes
it's in the scriptures okay